[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome back.
We've covered a lot
of ground already,
so today I want to review
and reinforce concepts.
To do that, we'll
explore two things.
First, we'll code
up a basic pipeline
for supervised learning.
I'll show you how
multiple classifiers
can solve the same problem.
Next, we'll build up a
little more intuition
for what it means for an
algorithm to learn something
from data, because that sounds
kind of magical, but it's not.
To kick things off, let's
look at a common experiment
you might want to do.
Imagine you're building
a spam classifier.
That's just a function that
labels an incoming email
as spam or not spam.
Now, say you've already
collected a data set
and you're ready
to train a model.
But before you put
it into production,
there's a question you
need to answer first--
how accurate will it be when you
use it to classify emails that
weren't in your training data?
As best we can, we want to
verify our models work well
before we deploy them.
And we can do an experiment
to help us figure that out.
One approach is to partition
our data set into two parts.
We'll call these Train and Test.
We'll use Train
to train our model
and Test to see how
accurate it is on new data.
That's a common pattern, so
let's see how it looks in code.
To kick things off, let's import
a data set into [? SyKit. ?]
We'll use Iris again, because
it's handily included.
Now, we already saw
Iris in episode two.
But what we haven't
seen before is
that I'm calling the
features x and the labels y.
Why is that?
Well, that's because one
way to think of a classifier
is as a function.
At a high level, you can
think of x as the input
and y as the output.
I'll talk more about that in
the second half of this episode.
After we import the data set,
the first thing we want to do
is partition it
into Train and Test.
And to do that, we can
import a handy utility,
and it makes the syntax clear.
We're taking our
x's and our y's,
or our features and labels,
and partitioning them
into two sets.
X_train and y_train are
the features and labels
for the training set.
And X_test and y_test are
the features and labels
for the testing set.
Here, I'm just saying that
I want half the data to be
used for testing.
So if we have 150 examples
in Iris, 75 will be in Train
and 75 will be in Test.
Now we'll create our classifier.
I'll use two
different types here
to show you how they
accomplish the same task.
Let's start with the decision
tree we've already seen.
Note there's only
two lines of code
that are classifier-specific.
Now let's train the classifier
using our training data.
At this point, it's ready
to be used to classify data.
And next, we'll call
the predict method
and use it to classify
our testing data.
If you print out
the predictions,
you'll see there are
a list of numbers.
These correspond
to the type of Iris
the classifier predicts for
each row in the testing data.
Now let's see how
accurate our classifier
was on the testing set.
Recall that up top, we have
the true labels for the testing
data.
To calculate our
accuracy, we can
compare the predicted
labels to the true labels,
and tally up the score.
There's a convenience
method in [? Sykit ?]
we can import to do that.
Notice here, our
accuracy was over 90%.
If you try this on your own, it
might be a little bit different
because of some randomness
in how the Train/Test
data is partitioned.
Now, here's something
interesting.
By replacing these two lines, we
can use a different classifier
to accomplish the same task.
Instead of using
a decision tree,
we'll use one called
[? KNearestNeighbors. ?]
If we run our experiment,
we'll see that the code
works in exactly the same way.
The accuracy may be
different when you run it,
because this classifier works
a little bit differently
and because of the randomness
in the Train/Test split.
Likewise, if we wanted to use a
more sophisticated classifier,
we could just import it
and change these two lines.
Otherwise, our code is the same.
The takeaway here is that while
there are many different types
of classifiers, at a high level,
they have a similar interface.
Now let's talk a little
bit more about what
it means to learn from data.
Earlier, I said we called the
features x and the labels y,
because they were the input
and output of a function.
Now, of course, a function
is something we already
know from programming.
def classify--
there's our function.
As we already know in
supervised learning,
we don't want to
write this ourselves.
We want an algorithm to
learn it from training data.
So what does it mean
to learn a function?
Well, a function is just
a mapping from input
to output values.
Here's a function you
might have seen before-- y
equals mx plus b.
That's the equation
for a line, and there
are two parameters-- m,
which gives the slope;
and b, which gives
the y-intercept.
Given these
parameters, of course,
we can plot the function
for different values of x.
Now, in supervised learning,
our classified function
might have some
parameters as well,
but the input x are the
features for an example we
want to classify,
and the output y
is a label, like Spam or Not
Spam, or a type of flower.
So what could the body of
the function look like?
Well, that's the part we
want to write algorithmically
or in other words, learn.
The important thing
to understand here
is we're not
starting from scratch
and pulling the body of the
function out of thin air.
Instead, we start with a model.
And you can think of a
model as the prototype for
or the rules that define
the body of our function.
Typically, a model
has parameters
that we can adjust
with our training data.
And here's a high-level example
of how this process works.
Let's look at a toy data set and
think about what kind of model
we could use as a classifier.
Pretend we're interested
in distinguishing
between red dots and
green dots, some of which
I've drawn here on a graph.
To do that, we'll use
just two features--
the x- and
y-coordinates of a dot.
Now let's think about how
we could classify this data.
We want a function
that considers
a new dot it's
never seen before,
and classifies it
as red or green.
In fact, there might be a lot
of data we want to classify.
Here, I've drawn
our testing examples
in light green and light red.
These are dots that weren't
in our training data.
The classifier has never
seen them before, so how can
it predict the right label?
Well, imagine if we
could somehow draw a line
across the data like this.
Then we could say
the dots to the left
of the line are green and dots
to the right of the line are
red.
And this line can serve
as our classifier.
So how can we learn this line?
Well, one way is to use
the training data to adjust
the parameters of a model.
And let's say the model we
use is a simple straight line
like we saw before.
That means we have two
parameters to adjust-- m and b.
And by changing them, we can
change where the line appears.
So how could we learn
the right parameters?
Well, one idea is that
we can iteratively adjust
them using our training data.
For example, we might
start with a random line
and use it to classify the
first training example.
If it gets it right, we don't
need to change our line,
so we move on to the next one.
But on the other hand,
if it gets it wrong,
we could slightly adjust
the parameters of our model
to make it more accurate.
The takeaway here is this.
One way to think of learning
is using training data
to adjust the
parameters of a model.
Now, here's something
really special.
It's called
tensorflow/playground.
This is a beautiful
example of a neural network
you can run and experiment
with right in your browser.
Now, this deserves its
own episode for sure,
but for now, go ahead
and play with it.
It's awesome.
The playground comes
with different data
sets you can try out.
Some are very simple.
For example, we could use our
line to classify this one.
Some data sets are
much more complex.
This data set is
especially hard.
And see if you can build
a network to classify it.
Now, you can think
of a neural network
as a more sophisticated
type of classifier,
like a decision tree
or a simple line.
But in principle,
the idea is similar.
OK.
Hope that was helpful.
I just created a Twitter
that you can follow
to be notified of new episodes.
And the next one should be
out in a couple of weeks,
depending on how much work I'm
doing for Google I/O. Thanks,
as always, for watching,
and I'll see you next time.